armed with machetes and
batons hundreds of churchgoers marched
through the town of Canan on the
outskirts of hai's capital Porto
Prince they want to rid the area of
gangs protesters searched
homes and a suspected gang member was
beaten to
death this machete is to cut off the
heads of those who are making the people
leave their homes because these gangs
make our lives unar terrible and destroy
the country we will stop
it I came to preach to the gains to
change their lives because this violence
is not good but as this group marched
through the
town the gang that controls the area
opened fire with machine
guns the gangs are shooting at
us I'm looking for
shelter local rights groups say many
people were killed and dozens wounded
and some people were kidnapped some have
accused the organizer of the march of
being irresponsible saying parishioners
with machetes were no match for gang
members armed with assault
weapons gang violence has grown out of
control in
Haiti up to 80% of Porto Prince is now
under the control of armed groups this
year alone 2,400 people have been killed
and nearly 1,000 kidnapped
fed up with the surgeon violence some
people organized a vigilante movement in
April that targets and kills suspected
gang members a spiraling Pion of
violence and every day members of the
public are increasingly paying the price
Alex beard Al jaer